[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire au moment même où le livre
blanc de la sécurité intérieure est en
cours d'élaboration sens et bâtir la
police du 21ème siècle les policiers
sont sur la brèche
leurs conditions de travail sont de plus
en plus difficile le climat de plus en
plus tendue on ne cesse de dénoncer les
violences policières et l'impunité dont
jouiraient les forces de l'ordre et puis
il ya la police municipale armée qui
gagne du terrain et la gendarmerie dont
on dit qu un syndicat de police
appellerait à son démantèlement alors
que fait la police on en débat avec nos
quatre invités tous policiers ou proches
de la police mais pas forcément d'accord
pour autant alors je vous les présente
tout de suite nicolas pucheu 15 ans dans
la police police-secours compagnie de
sécurisation et d'intervention brigade
anticriminalité de nuit unité de
sécurisation des transports en commun
franciliens vous êtes allés jusqu'au
grade de brigadier chef de police est
aujourd'hui secrétaire départemental
adjoint paris unsa police l'unsa-police
c'est l'un des trois plus importants
syndicats policiers
alors on dit que le climat serait de
plus en plus tendues entre la police et
la population qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous mais en effet depuis un an
et demi
la france est en proie à des conflits
sociaux extrêmement intense où la police
a été mise à contribution et asservi et
finalement de bras armé à l'exécutif
pourrait tenir la république parce qu'à
un moment donné on n'était pas loin que
la république ne vacille et ça a créé un
gros clivage une grosse fracture avec la
population en effet
et aujourd'hui on en est arrivé à un
climat réellement également délétère
nauséabond entre la population et la
police n'a manoir vous à 8 ans à la
direction des renseignements de la
préfecture de police de paris dans votre
viseur il y avait al-qaïda les premières
filiales jihadistes vers la syrie
l'islam radical donc filatures
surveillances écoutes téléphoniques vous
avez raconté tout se fait dans un livre
qui a fait polémique à sa sortie en
septembre 2019 la france doit savoir aux
éditions plon
vous êtes également délégué du syndicat
à vigy police le climat est de plus en
plus tendue vous confirmez évidemment en
fait ce qu'on reproche aujourd'hui à la
police c'est d'appliquer de façon très
stricte les consignes qui lui sont
données notamment parié sur la petite
couronne par le préfet de police dont on
dit qui le gouvernent entre guillemets
ou qu'ils assurent la sécurité d'une
main de fer
maintenant on est quand même à un moment
clé puisque aujourd'hui a eu lieu
justement le compte rendu de l'enquêté
parlementaire qui est consécutif savez à
l'attack de la préfecture de police dont
on sait aujourd'hui de façon sûre qu'il
s'agissait d'une attaque terroriste
on a également cette préconisation vous
l'avez dit effectivement d'un syndicat
de police mais pas n'importe lequel le
syndicat des commissaires de police qui
appelle à la dissolution de la
gendarmerie
donc vous voyez on est quand même dans
une phase jeu-là de l'histoire sans
précédent point de vue notre institution
et notamment avec les relations avec la
population de son cannes finalement qu'à
volet de cette déconfiture gélas de tous
les aspects des aspects concrets sur le
terrain mais également des aspects
relationnels institutionnels liés à ce
que devient aujourd'hui la police
nationale dans toutes ces dérives
lionel tourtier vous n'êtes pas policier
vous êtes cadre à la retraite mais vous
êtes l'un des premiers adhérents de
l'association uniforme en danger qui
alertent depuis trois ans sur la
dégradation des conditions de travail
dans les métiers de la sécurité publique
le climat de plus en plus tendu dans
lequel se trouvent les personnes en
uniforme et le nombre de suicides dans
la police en particulier
alors vous aussi vous constatez c'est
cette tension entre la population et la
police
alors depuis 2005 à vous rappeler
charlie lorsque
il y avait sept trotteuse y ait des
effets tout forme pc aujourd'hui ne peut
pas dire oui les choses se sont pas
arrangées et elles se sont pas arrangées
pas simplement niveau des forces de
police elle même et aux petits de tout
ce qui a trait à leur environnement
familial parce que on a chez nous dans
notre association d'aidé des membres des
forces de police ou et des femmes
notamment qui se plaignent de
harcèlement d'être suivie à leur
domicile d'avoir leurs enfants aussi
menacé donc la dégradation elle a pris
une tournure de violence qui est quand
même extrêmement préoccupante pour les
forces de l'ordre de leur famille comme
jean-pierre colombie ex commandant de
police disant aux dupuis chef de groupe
chargé des atteintes aux personnes à
marseille
ensuite commissariat de neuilly sur
seine puis de boulogne billancourt et
paris 16e
vous êtes est également impliquée dans
la vie syndicale vous avez été
porte-parole de l'association de police
upm ni l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants une association apolitique
et à syndicale de policiers en colère
qui travaille à l'amélioration des
conditions de travail de tous les
salariés du ministère de l'intérieur
depuis vous êtes comédiens vous joué
notamment dans othello hamlet et conte
d'hiver de shakespeare au théâtre du
nord-ouest et vous êtes l'auteur de deux
m'a peut-être aux éditions de
l'harmattan
ce sont les derniers instants d'un
communards le climat donc de plus en
plus tendue vous le confirmez vous aussi
oui je crois que
ce serait à tenir une langue de bois
avant une langue de bois que dira le
contraire ce qui est problématique c'est
qu'on malheureusement on peut que
conclure au fait que c'était provoquer
que cette situation a servi à détourner
l'attention d'une véritable crise
sociale qui est née il ya maintenant un
an et demi qu'on a qualifié de manière
un peu synthétiques même raccourcie de
gilet jaune mais qui était le révélateur
que une frange notable de la population
avait besoin de se faire entendre par
rapport à des décisions qu'elle était
qu'on lui qu'on essayait de lui imposer
et finalement ça arrange et pas mal de
personnes que le débat se résume à une
opposition policy tonalité ce qu'on a
d'ailleurs très souvent au travers de
cette association eu de cesse que de
dénoncer en disant attention en lançant
des signaux d'alarmé que cette situation
ne pouvait qu'avoir des conséquences
néfastes pour les propres policiers pour
des fonctionnaires de police qui était à
la fois confronté à ça oco des
manifestations mais aussi de manière
plus générale dans le cadre d'un rapport
police citoyenne t alors commence
aujourd'hui par ces violences policières
le gouvernement les énigmes et lors des
noces dénonciation est devenue
récurrente alors comment les expliquez
vous et comment comment lutter contre
nicolas plus je sais quoi le problème
c'est pas seulement les petites caméras
de vidéo sur l'auto aujourd'hui tout le
monde est équipé qui permet de filmer
effectivement les cas de violences
policières
le problème c'est que il faudrait déjà
sortir de cette verse de cette vision
manichéenne des choses ou
on pourrait penser qu'il ya d'un côté le
pauvre peuple les pauvres gilet jaune et
de l'autre pardonnez moi cette
expression un peu triviale c'est ça
notre fric parce qu'en fin de compte un
flic c'est d'abord un citoyen c'est bien
souvent également un gilet jaune par
gilet jaune j'entends classes moyennes
prolétaires ce que vous voulez faire
quelqu'un qui ne subsiste que par le
biais de ses revenus qui n'a pas de
revenus annexes
c'est bien quelqu'un c'est bien souvent
quelqu'un qui a du mal à joindre les
deux bouts et ce qui est dramatique dans
cette situation c'est qu'on a opposé des
policiers
donc ils font partie du peuple et qui
subissent qui traverse les mêmes
problématiques que le peuple précisément
on les a opposés au peuple pour
finalement comme le disait parfaitement
monsieur colombiès pour résoudre un
conflit une crise politique sauf que là
on pouvait pas répondre comme ça de avec
en usant de la force publique n'était
pas une réponse autoritaire qui
attendait le peuple c'était une réponse
sociétale dames et là on a vu des
slogans rejoignez nous sur les
banderoles souvent trouvé pris entre le
marteau et l'enclume
parce que il a il n'a jamais été aussi
difficile qu'aujourd'hui d'être
fonctionnaire de police
néanmoins inquiet des violences on sait
qu'il ya des caméras que tout quasiment
toutes les violences aujourd'hui sans
filmer et pourtant il y en a toujours
comment comment l'expliquer jean pierre
colombet c'est le plus naturellement du
monde c'est à dire que lorsque vous
laisser s'installer une situation de
crispation d'hypertension d'hyper
violence que vous laissez monter une
pression insupportable à tous les
niveaux à un moment donné que vous avez
une confrontation directe qui arrive est
bien évidemment il est impossible que
tout se passe proprement gère bien malin
celui qui pourrait avoir la prétention
de considérer qu'une manifestation de
l'ampleur qu'on a connu des
manifestations ça quand même duré un an
et demi bien malin qui pourrait avoir la
prétention d'instaurer un système de
maintien de l'ordre qui soit nickel si
vous rajoutez à cela je dirais des dlc
d'ailleurs s'était dénoncée par des
organisations syndicales une certaine
époque et également par l'association
des problématiques d'organisation
d'encadrement de ces manifestations pour
faire simple quand vous avez nommé ray
toutes sortes d'effectifs qui ne sont
pas toutes nécessairement formé au
maintien de l'ordre nécessairement vous
avez des problèmes de coordination et je
dirais de bon sens de
de l'action de l'action policière ça
n'arrive pas des problématiques de cet
ordre là n'arrivent pas dès lors que
vous avez en face de manifestants des
forces de police
habituée entraînés à gérer ce genre de
situation c'est beaucoup plus complexe
quand vous agrégé des polices
périphériques de petit couronne de
service qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude de
travailler ensemble et de fait vous avez
vous ouvrez la porte mais à leur grande
ouverte à ce qu'il y ait des
problématiques dont les premières
victimes peuvent être effectivement les
policiers mais aussi des manifestants
parce qu'ils sont pris parfois entre
deux feux vous avez des activistes
dangereux très décidée très organisés
qu'on appelle les black blocks le
système black blocks vous en avez
d'autres si vous avez des identitaires
mais vous avez aussi des gens qui
étaient pris dans la nasse et qui ont
été mêlés à des actions d'envergure de
hyper violente mais qui n'y étaient
strictement pour rien c'est ce qui est
dénoncée en permanence et je vois qu'il
ya eu des manifestations on a dit tout à
coup les manifestants se retrouvent dans
la nasse et où on commençait à voir
il suffisait d'aller assister à ces
manifestations même ne serait ce qu'en
tant que spectateur ce que j'ai fait
parce que je voulais savoir un peu de
quoi on parle et de quoi il en
retournait et j'ai vu quoi j'ai vu comme
tout un chacun aura pu le constater des
familles des couples des retraités même
des enfants c'était pas très malin de
mon point de vue mais enfin bon il y
avait tout et puis vous aviez des
activistes très bien organisée qui
savait exactement ce qu'il faisait qui
était dans la foule et qui faisait en
sorte de créer de ses points de fixation
ces points de crispation auquel
abandonné fallait bien répondre et de
fait lorsque vous chargez lorsque les
forces de police ont pour mission de
charger et de dégager
c'est impossible d'avoir une action
entre guillemets propres manor sais je
dirais que à l'analyse effectivement je
suis plutôt d'accord mais je peux
constater après 18 mois finalement de
crise sociale
l'errance du gouvernement l'absence
totale d'idées puisque vous savez il ya
quelques mois j'ai été témoin justement
de tout et acteurs d'ailleurs de tous
ces débats autour de ce qu'on avait
appelé le fichier anti casseurs c'est à
dire que le premier ministre en personne
avait pris la parole à l'antenne
relayé par toutes les grandes chaînes
d'informations en lisant ça y est les
services de renseignements ont été à
même d'identifier les black blocks les
casseurs on va les neutraliser en les
assignant à domicile et les jours de
manifestation en les obligeant à la
pointe au commissariat ce qui va
permettre justement aux manifestants
pacifistes de pouvoir
intégrée de pouvoir garantir en gros la
liberté de manifester de ces personnes
le fichier anti casseur est née quelques
mois après aucun changement peut être
une aggravation justement des violences
policières à l'occasion des
manifestations mais ce ne sont pas les
seuls et donc naturellement bon bah si
vous voulez le gouvernement ne répond
pas aujourd'hui face justement à ces
échecs parce que c'est bien de ça dont
il s'agit
alors que le débat sur le fichier anti
casseurs a duré trois semaines donc il a
été voté par la majorité
retoqué au conseil constitutionnel un
moment sur le terrain l'efficacité et la
légitimité justement de cette action
sont ça va quand même un coup derrière
et puis il ya une légitimité de la part
justement des manifestants à demander
des comptes au gouvernement et
aujourd'hui s'ils voulaient le le débat
est totalement inexistant ensuite les
violences policières se sont pas que les
manifestations on a le cas par exemple
récent de cédric joue via qui a été
effectivement malencontreusement tués au
moment d'une interpellation donc on a un
texte de loi qui va être votée en mars
justement pour l'interdiction du placage
ventrale donc on voit bien qu'il ya en
gestation certain nombre de
problématiques qui résultent justement
en général de l'emploi de la force
publique et de la coercition et vous
savez après le dernier point que je vais
souligné très rapidement c'est celui de
la régulation c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'institution igpn ne
fonctionne pas pas plus tard qu'hier
l'inspection générale des services louis
la police des polices globalement et qui
concerne également une juste la police
parce que s'ils voulaient dans l'opinion
publique
parra pour répondre à votre question je
pense que la gendarmerie la police
municipale des douanes n'ont pas les
mêmes problèmes que la police nationale
du point de vue en tout cas des
relations avec le public donc écouter
les peines ne fonctionne pas hier vous
si vous écumez les réseaux sociaux vous
allez voir qu'il ya le cas d'un jeune
garçon qui a reçu une munition de l bd
en pleine mâchoire dont la mâchoire
était fracturée il a perdu 5 dans sa vie
sa capacité justement d'autonomie ont
été altérés par cet incident l'igpn
écrit noir sur blanc nous n'avons pas
été en mesure d'identifier l'auteur du
tir est donc classement sans suite de la
plainte donc la personne n'obtiendra
jamais justice tout comme la famille de
zineb redouane tout comme cette
geneviève le gehani c'est peut-être la
famille steve kadi so si on considère
que la mutation d'un chef de dispositif
est une justice écoutez j'ai une
définition la justice qui est plus
ambitieuse que celle ci
et effectivement on se rend bien compte
que c'est un chantier pharaonique et que
quand on en est qu'au début si vous
voulez et les policiers qui ne met pas
les numéros qui n'affichent pas le
numéro qui sont censé afficher bien j'ai
enfin bon personnellement sur le sujet
je pense que c'est un faux débat là la
poêle pour joindre un peu l'idée
l'esprit de ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est que il est vrai que depuis plus
d'un an maintenant on est confronté à un
double langage c'est un peu le langage
du pompiers incendiaires
c'est à dire le on a eu droit à des
prises de parole gouvernemental plus que
maladroite qui encouragent et une
crispation vraiment vraiment forte de
vis à vis de la population appuie en
face à ceux réponse qu'on avait c'était
bien alors l'on voit les régiments de
policiers qui vont nous régler tout ça
c'est pour moi et pas que pour moi du
reste un c'est pas raisonnable c'est
tout simplement pas raisonnable ni
cohérent pour ne peut pas régler cette
problématique sociale elle est profonde
uniquement en y répondant par la force
en tout cas par la fonction publique par
les policiers qui je le rappelle sont
touchés par toutes les réformes c'est et
souligné effectivement les policiers de
base et même de grade intermédiaires je
voudrais un petit peu à part une forme
de caste policière qui l est est
indépendante de ce qui concerne de
toutes les préoccupations de base mais
il ya véritablement une problématique de
je dirais de discours et de philosophie
d'emploi c'est ça aussi surtout qu'il
faut parler qu'elle est qu'est ce que
l'on veut faire de la police dans ce
pays
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai débat quelle
est la philosophie d'emploi on à la
police qu'on mérite un globalement
quelque part un dès lors que l'on met en
place un pouvoir qui a cette attitude là
faut pas s'en plaindre quand il dit on à
la police qu'on mérite ça veut dire que
la population mairie pour que le
gouvernement mais c'est un peu des yeux
même chose c'est un peu c'est un peu des
deux si vous dès lors que vous mettez en
place des gouvernants qui tiennent un
discours très radicale
salut j'ai 35 ans de police derrière moi
j'ai eu 30 50 points à peu près va faire
l'économie d'une année ou deux j'ai vu
une succession police de pardon de
politique sécuritaire qui était aussi
inopérantes les unes que les autres et
il fallait régulièrement je dirais tenir
la société uniquement par le bon vouloir
et la bonne volonté des fonctionnaires
de terrain à un moment donné ce système
ne tient plus parce que vous ne savez
plus de toute façon quel est le sens de
votre métier et ça rejoint le débat
qu'on va évoquer sur les suicides et le
mal être
dès lors que vous ne savez plus quel est
le sens de ce que vous faites est
nécessairement semaines assure du
mal-être donc des dépressions et des
suicides sachant qu'il ya aussi pas mal
de dépression et puis le rapport avec la
citoyenneté avec la population lorsque
vous avez des policiers enfin des
politiques pardon qui vont de la police
de proximité qui ré inventé l'eau tiède
à une police de résultats hystérique et
ensuite une police absolument
une politique sécuritaire qui est
indéchiffrable plus personne n'y
comprend rien et des policiers comme de
la citoyenneté faut écouter ce que
veulent les gens en termes de polices il
demande parce qu'ils aient plus de
police y compris ce que l'on appelle les
gilet jaune demande pas ça du tout ils
demandent au contraire une police avec
laquelle on puisse dialoguer qu'ils
soient des vrais partenaires et pas
simplement des uniformes bleus il ya un
livre important qui a été publiée à
quelques années c'est de la pollution
démocratie de sébastian roché où il
faisait remarquer que la france est et
de tous les pays d'europe celui où la
population est le moins confiance dans
sa police tout quelques classes sociales
confondues
mon nom ça demanderait est révolue et je
pense oui oui c'est moi ça m'étonne pas
du tout si je puis me permettre
parce que si vous voulez vous regardez
même le système d'assermentation en fin
de compte des policiers français
globalement il n'est pas aussi autant au
point je dirais que par exemple que
celui des pays anglo saxons moi je suis
allé au royaume-uni déjà tous les
policiers ne sont pas armés parce que le
recours justement à la force est quand
même beaucoup moins évident et
systématique qu'en france en france on
patrouille à 2 parce qu'il faut
effectivement un partenaire ou un
collègue pour intervenir en protection
mais également pour témoigner parce que
la parole d'un seul policier ne suffit
pas justement à établir une certitude
alors que unis quand un policier j'ai
déjà assisté à une verbalisation
justement au pays de galles où un
policier a dit à une personne vous êtes
en excès de vitesse ou en vitesse
excessive même si la vitesse n'était pas
mesuré le policier étaient habilités à
dresser un procès verbal pour vitesse
excessive sur une simple constatation
disant monsieur vous rouler trop vite
sur dans cette rue elle voyait en france
il faut un appareil il faut un équipage
plusieurs témoins faut que l'appareil
était conforme et est validée par la
drire etc sinon effectivement il ya un
vice de procédure donc voyez on est à
des années-lumière justement du policier
dont la parole ne peut pas être remise
en question la probité
voilà rien et le portier
vous redonner un éclairage un peu plus
en profondeur je souscris à tout ce qui
a été dit mais je crois qu'il faut
regarder la situation l'avait évoqué la
situation sociale de ce pays
en fait on est un pays qui est
aujourd'hui en crise et qui a de
profondes angoisse est en fait le la
violence elle résulte du fait que vous
savez pas traiter l'angoissent et que le
politique depuis vingt ans ne s'est pas
très bien par rapport à la
désindustrialisation
on l'a réaffecter beaucoup d'emplois
dans des activités tertiaires à faible
valeur ajoutée donc à faible
rémunération
on a eu les politiques du logement qui
ont fait que les gens étaient obligé de
s'excentrer donc avec des problèmes de
transport de pouvoir d'achat et donc si
on prend pas en considération que il ya
un vrai problème social dans ce pipe et
que l'on joue l'autisme
d'ailleurs on l'a on veut le le
l'ignorer voir le mépriser comme ça a
été au début des jeux il est clair vous
avez des réactions mais vous avez les
réactions qui au départ n'était pas
agressive qui était revendicative
ce qu'il ya c'est qu'on a des forces
extrémistes dans ce pays qui procède
avec sophisme c'est à dire le le pouvoir
est forcément violent la police est le
vecteur du pouvoir donc la police est
violente et voilà à partir de ce moment
on fait des amalgames et on ignore
complètement le rôle social
d'accompagnement peut avoir les forces
de l'ordre dans plusieurs missions on
les agresse et on les agresse parce que
quelque part c'est une dynamique qui est
en train de se construire de
déstabilisation de l'ordre républicain
c'est pour ça qu'en tant que citoyen moi
je réagis parce que je crois que ya le
problème de l'organisation des forces de
l'ordre etc
mais il ya aussi un problème social
extrêmement grave et qui ne risque pas
de s'arranger
et donc ça veut dire que le les tensions
entre le pouvoir
la police et les citoyens ils sont
plutôt selon moi devant si on prend pas
des mesures que derrière et dans les
changements aussi il ya également le
fait que la population
française connaît une grande diversité y
compris dans les couleurs et et que la
police est suivi régulièrement
l'accusation d'être raciste d'opérer des
contrôles au faciès et seat star vous
même vous l'a crédité d'une certaine
manière dans votre livre
alors que la pulsion à cette accusation
qui revient en permanence que la police
serait raciste
écoutez si je prends mon cas personnel
parce que en tant que policier
moi j'ai été élevée par des parents
plutôt de gauche avec des valeurs plutôt
axé tourné vers le social de tolérance
devant vous j'ai pas découvert charlie
hebdo lors des attentats mois et est du
coup j'ai intégré la police nationale
française en me disant que c'était
l'image de ce que j'espérais que ce soit
donc quelque chose dit reprochable
déontologiques en tout cas faut pas
oublier que pour répondre à votre
question il faut pas oublier que la
police est constituée d'hommes qui
allait donc allez donc pluriel que
chacun ses convictions ses croyances le
tout c'est de ne pas les exposer
quand on revêt l'habit de lumière on a
bien sûr que kia des policiers qui
peuvent avoir certaines idées qui sont
peut-être pas en adéquation avec ce
qu'on attend d'un des valeurs de la
république ou d'un fonctionne de police
mais du moment qu'il reste au vestiaire
ses idées peu importe l'idée c'est que
quand on revêt l'habit de lumière on est
un représentant de l'état et qu'à partir
des landes à faire abstraction de toutes
ses convictions religieuses politiques
ou associatives et dans l'exercice de
mes fonctions j'ai déjà pu observer des
comportements qu'on pourrait
caractériser de déviants bien sûr parce
qu'un policier reste un homme mais ya
pas plus de policiers d'evian que deux
boulangers déviants ou que deux
fleuristes d'evian sauf que dès lors que
vous avez un pouvoir coercitif ça se
voit plus après vous parlez de contrôle
au faciès
faut savoir que lorsqu'on contrôle des
individus c'est toujours dans le cadre
d'une réquisition enfin l'a4 en général
c'est soit parce qu'ils la commission
d'une infraction soit parce qu'on a une
réquisition qui nous est délivré par le
procureur de la république et qui nous
permet de contrôler en un lieu donné et
sur un créneau horaire donner toute
personne qui transitent dans ce lieu est
évidemment parce que les alors parce que
les statistiques le montrent ou parce
que tout ce que vous voulez on va plutôt
s'orienter vers des personnes qui
présentent ce que nous on pensait être
les stigmates de l'un des vacances donc
des signes extérieurs d'appartenance
plutôt que vers une vieille dame avec
son caddie s est peut-être que on passe
à côté de 15 kilos de résine de cannabis
dans le cadre il peut être mais mais
c'est vrai que j'appellerais pas tant sa
du délit de faciès que du bon sens dans
l'exercice de nos fonctions
mais voyez ma réponse est pas totalement
elle est nuancée dans le sens où je vous
dis un policier reste un homme et moi du
moment que ces idées aussi nauséabondes
certes elle reste au vestiaire moi ça me
dérange pas c'est du moment que je vois
là il faut être nos lames et noir
effectivement je peux chaque pièce sur
le discours mais effectivement moi je
pense pas au quotidien que ces idées
restent au vestiaire moi ce sont les gg
par exemple assister à un conseil de
discipline il ya environ trois semaines
et on a révoqué une fonctionnaire de
police parce qu'elle avait rédigé en
2014 de tweets pro palestiniens elle les
avait pas rédigé d'ailleurs elle est à
re tweeté en fait et en cours
comparativement à ce que j'observe sur
le terrain s'ils voulaient j'observe
encore une malheureusement le même
problème que celui que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est un problème de régulation
c'est à dire qu'il ya une disproportion
étonnante entre ce qu'on va rechercher
aujourd'hui c'est à dire notamment dans
les critères d'application de la laïcité
on va appeler ça pour pas appeler ça de
la discrimination très clairement c'est
à dire que après par exemple la sphère
michael harpon les propos de castaner ou
du ministre de l'intérieur par donc elle
a répondu voilà c'est le ceto à la
préfecture de police tout à fait
fonctionnaires et il nous a donné la
définition de ce que serait un signe de
radicalité religieuse incompatible avec
l'exercice des fonctions de policier
donc ce serait un refus de l'autorité ou
une soeur une forme de rejet de
l'autorité hiérarchique quelques poils
de barbe sous le menton une pratique
accrue peut-être de la religion
musulmane pendant la période du ramadan
et à côté de ça au quotidien
effectivement dans les équipages de
police et d'ailleurs je vous annonce ce
soir qu' à titre syndical on a récupéré
un certain nombre d'enregistrements de
patrouille à qui on est et qui ont été
j'irai des dont la capture a été
effectué et justement en dehors d'eux
aux réserves de façon discrète parce que
en réponse justement aux propos du
ministre donateurs qui avec ses quais
qui a expliqué le 5 février dernier à
l'antenne de vos confrères de france
inter qu'il n'y avait pas de racisme
antimaghrébin ou anti musulmans dans la
police lui l'a affirmé comme une
certitude
donc nous allons nous exercer à lui
démontrer le contraire justement et je
pense qu'il le sait très bien dans le
fond si vous voulez la difficulté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement le
gouvernement a besoin de la police donc
tout est fait pour que le ministre de
l'intérieur ne se met pas justement la
police via les syndicats majoritaires à
dos les syndicats de police sont
politisés de toute façon bon j'ai pas de
problème particulier avec l'un ou
l'autre mais là pendant l'entre-deux
tours des élections présidentielles
syndicat alliance à donner une consigne
de vote favorable à emmanuel macron
effectivement les quel est ce que c'est
bien le rôle d'un syndicat professionnel
de fonctionnaires d'ailleurs c'est à
dire et de police de surcroît donc quand
même les attentes en matière de
neutralité et de réserve sont plus
importantes que dans d'autres corps que
de donner des consignes de vote au
moment des élections présidentielles
vous voyez à un moment on voit bien
qu'il ya un usage du droit du règlement
administratif à géométrie variable
c'est-à-dire que bon globalement et
peut-être légitimement vous êtes pro
palestiniens vous êtes viré si vous
l'exprimer mais aujourd'hui dans la
police et j'assume pleinement mon propos
quand vous êtes raciste anti noir anti
arabes anti musulman ou anti ce que vous
voulez et parfois même antisémite
d'ailleurs il ya une forme de tolérance
que je ne m'explique pas est un exemple
très précis du tribunal du tgi de rouen
qui date d'environ un mois qu'il
démontre très bien les extraits audio
ont été mis en ligne par certains de vos
confrères où les mots c'est vrai pendant
des mois et des semaines entières
[ __ ] biko juifs [ __ ] etc
s'il ya une déferlante de haine raciale
justement sur des échanges entre les
fonctionnaires de police
et si vous voulez moi je ne m'explique
pas la faible réaction avec un
communiqué rapide pour dire que je crois
que le fonctionnaire qui avait signalé
les faits qui lui est d'origine
antillaise a été déplacé donc moi si
j'avais été ministre de l'intérieur ce
qui n'arrivera jamais donc je peux me
permettre justement moi j'aurais
déplacer les dix personnes responsables
justement des propos et j'aurais laissé
la victime en place justement au tj dron
là on a joué et alter ont fait une pause
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
que fait la police on reprend notre
débat avec nicolas pucheu qui est
secrétaire départemental adjoint paris
unsa police avec dom
anwar délégué du syndicat vigiles police
avec lionel tourtier de l'association
uniforme en danger avec jean-pierre
colombiès ex porte-parole de l'union des
policiers municipaux indique nos dépens
des nationaux indépendants pardonnez moi
et ex commandant de police par la même
occasion vous allez vous donner la
parole avant course interrompue
oui parce que beaucoup de sujets ont été
évoqués comme ça c'est parti un petit
peu avec beaucoup beaucoup de flèches et
beaucoup de pistes de remarques de
réflexion pourquoi aussi on en est à un
point où la perception de la police est
quasi impossible pour une citoyenneté
mais tout simplement ce qu'elle ne les
voit plus on a supprimé ce qui faisait
le lien un lien quotidien ce qu'on a
appelé très globalement la police de
proximité
j'ai connu une époque pas si éloigné que
ça où il y avait des îlotiers dans les
quartiers qui étaient pas là que pour
mettre des pv pas là que pour
interpeller les gens et il y avait un
lien concret permanent entre
l'institution le service public l'état
et la citoyenneté tout simplement les
citoyens quel qu'il soit quel que soit
j'ai envie de dire leur couleur leur
origine et pour aller par contre sur
l'idée de la crispation entre des
étrangers et la police pas je suis
désolé mais on peut pas faire l'impasse
sur l'époque sarkozyste qui a été
particulièrement redoutable lorsqu'il
s'agissait de montrer ses muscles par
rapport au front national justement il
faut les démontrer que la politique anti
je dirais étrangers en situation
régulière et est efficace ou des
instructions ont été données de ratisser
très large au travers justement des
réquisitions de police couverte par le
l'ensemble des parquets sous l'autorité
des préfets où il fallait impérativement
arrêter des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers d'étrangers pour en expulser à
minima certains pour justifier cette
politique de deux bras musclés donc ça
c'est catastrophique pour l'image que
justement qui va en découler
alors bon bien évidemment si en plus de
ça vous assurez la promotion des gens
les plus aisés en cette matière va vous
arriver
à une situation relationnelle
particulièrement crispé lionel tourtier
oui je souscris à l'importance de la
police de proximité je dirais que d'une
certaine manière la police municipale
joue le ce rôle aujourd'hui parce que
c'est le maire qui est responsable de la
sécurité est de plus en plus bonjour
pour des policiers municipaux et il ya
un contact beaucoup plus social bon il
ya un autre aspect parfaitement qu'elle
n'a pas les mêmes obligations
non je suis d'accord mais oui c'est
quand même dans la cité dans le village
pour autant qu'il ya des pays ici mais
dc pos c'est quand même un lien où on
peut discuter
ils font de la prévention ils
connaissent les ados qui chahutent un
peu et c'est donc mais j'aimerais qu'on
s'arrête justement sur ces pays
municipales et notamment la police
municipale armée qui gagnerait par être
filmée mais s'il faut faire du problème
est ce que je me demande c'est parce que
les policiers deviennent des cibles
quels qu'ils soient l'eire policier
national ou policiers municipaux ça
devient des symboles et dès lors que
effectivement les exposent à de plus en
plus de situations critiques qu'ils
aient la capacité de se défendre
enfin regardez combien de policiers sont
renversés sciemment par des voitures etc
bong a alors donné d'ailleurs non
clarissa jean-philippe au moment des
attitudes charlie wi
par exemple je veux dire c'est pas
illogique que l'on puisse donner aux
forces de l'ordre a ordonné les moyens
de se défendre
avec toutes les contraintes de des
dispositions sur la légitimité
mais vous savez aussi que la police
française est une des polices qui tout
le moins c'est tout à son honneur mais
trouve où l'armée et plus vous porte
puis il ya triste qu'on lui tire dessus
qu'elle réplique oui ça faisait quand
même aux prises avec le terrorisme alors
peut-être que on a mieux géré depuis 5 7
ans pour la faire mais rien ne dit qu'on
va pas avoir de nouveaux problèmes de
cette nature là et que
les forces de l'ordre notamment la
police la gendarmerie et la police
municipale voir les sv père qui
circulent et c'est à ce sont des
sandales sont des symboles qui se dit
ils sont touchés si les six rien pour se
défendre
on les envoie au casse mais violet la
vie des policiers sur ce sujet le fait
que la boutique puis police municipale
armée gagne du terrain
qu'en pense la police nationale les avis
sont partagés parce qu'en fait on a tout
un tas de missions dites indus dont on
aimerait bien pouvoir se dégager pour
assurer nos véritables missions
régaliennes et si la police municipale
vient nous prêter main forte sur ses
missions que nous considérons comme
étant des mets des émissions un du
détachant du alors là bien sûr on
souscrit totalement à cette idée il
faudrait pas en revanche que
que les polices municipales obtiennent
les mêmes prérogatives de manière totale
et inconditionnelle que celle de que
nous avons aujourd'hui je voulais juste
revenir sur ce qui avait été évoqué sur
la juste un petit point sur la fracture
police population et je souscris
parfaitement à ce que ce qui a été dit
par monsieur colombiès moi je là j'étais
déjà dans la police à cette époque et je
la relève de la date au moment où
effectivement monsieur sarkozy est
arrivé au pouvoir en mettant en place
cette politique du chiffre
tiens a entraîné une véritable fracture
président de la république ou déjà
ministre de l'intérieur avait déjà
comment un militaire cette fracture
police-population où effectivement on
était soumis à des quotas à de
véritables quotas et notamment des
quotas qui rompu le stigmatiser
incertain pendant une certaine frange de
la population puisque née notamment des
potes des gens issus de l'immigration en
situation irrégulière et et politique du
chiffre
alimentée et encouragé par la mise en
place de primes clivante et qui sont
toujours d'actualité parce que c'est ça
aussi la grosse hypocrisie d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on dit on en est revenu de la
politique du chiffre c'est faux les
quotas existent toujours
on applique une politique mercantile
alors qu'on traite de l'humain on ne
traite pas des objets on traite de
l'humain comment quand vous partez en
patrouille seul l'initiative devrait
devrait être le maître mot
or là vous partez en patrouille avec des
objectifs qui vous sont fixés les
objectifs chiffrés et qui qui créé de
véritable clivage au sein même de la
police puisque c'est ses objectifs s'ils
sont atteints sont récompensés par des
primes au mérite individuelle ou
collective et ça c'est un véritable
problème et ça ça engendre et générer
une véritable perte de sens aux métiers
également qui a conquis conduit
notamment à ses extrémités à ces drames
que sont les suicides dans la profession
d'un manoir normand sur la question vous
avez posé sur la police municipale alors
effectivement c'est bien vous la poser
parce que à titre personnel moi je
j'envisage de me réorienter justement
vers la police municipale dans la mesure
où je considère en fait qu'elle
représente l'avenir justement de la
police
en général la police de proximité
notamment de ce qu'on appelle la police
secours je crois qu'on est quand on
observe à ce que la situation plus
globalement on est en fait dans une
sorte d' américanisation en fait de la
société française où finalement
l'ensemble des services sont privatisés
saufs
on a également un certain nombre de
dispositifs de sécurité et la sncf a sa
propre police la ratp aussi donc on a d
une généralisation comme ça de tous les
services de de la privatisation de ce
qui était autrefois des services publics
et donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement on a de toute façon on
observe une disparité entre les
territoires
selon que vous ayez un maire qui décide
d'investir massivement sur la sécurité
la vidéosurveillance la police
municipale sur le village d'à côté où la
ville d'à côté si le maire n'investit
pas vous avez quand même un déséquilibre
du point de vue justement des services
publics parce que l'état déserté ces
zones la police secours aujourd'hui en
commissariat c'est quelque chose qui
était totalement démantelée et
abandonner c'est à dire comment il n'est
pas rare que parfois que j'ai pu faire
appel en tant qu'usagers à la police
nationale en disant ben voilà il ya un
véhicule qui gêne qui est mal garée à
tel endroit qui est qui bloquent la
circulation et qu'on me réponde en un
seul équipage qui est déjà mobilisée sur
un différend conjugal ou sur une affaire
plus importante et on pourra pas se
déplacer dans ces moments là vous dise
effectivement la seule issue c'est que
le maire ait pu organiser une police
municipale après moi je me lâche je la
met pas directement en concurrence avec
la police nationale je considère pas que
ce sont des yeux que ce soit des gens
gênant ce sont des partenaires de
sécurité au quotidien complément
effectivement ils marchent pas sur nos
plates bandes mais quelque part je pense
que tout est fait en réalité le prisme
de badiou de la création de dd police
municipale des autorisations qui leur
sont donnés justement pour pouvoir
posséder de l'armement et c'est
absolument nécessaire à mon sens dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui de
menace terroriste et de menaces diverses
c'est que effectivement à terme la
police municipale va remplacer en fait
la police secours d'applis achat je
pense que la police nationale va
conserver ces drogues ses prérogatives
en matière de police fédérale entre
guillemets c'est à dire comme aux
espoirs seniors autres le shérif et le
renseignement intervention maintien de
l'ordre police judiciaire est en fait je
pense que la police secours va être
déléguées au maire et que comme aux
états unis justement les maires vont
devoir rendre compte en matière de
sécurité d'ailleurs l'exemple le plus
frappant c'est paris c'est à dire que
jusqu'à cette année on nous expliquait
qu'à paris les pouvoirs de police
étaient
exclusivement révolus au préfet de
police que l'appareil était la seule
ville de france pour la pour laquelle
dans laquelle en tout cas le maire
n'avait pas de pouvoir de police il
était dessaisi au profit du préfet de
police et on a créé la police municipale
parisienne justement cette année on a
démobilisé des effectifs de la
préfecture de police pour les rattacher
à la mairie de paris et on a créé cette
police municipale et je crois c'est
quelque chose qui va évoluer partout en
france jusqu'à la disparition en fait de
la police secours ils en acquièrent
colombiès we fuck bouche fine analyse et
qui est qui qui va dans ce sens là avec
quelques nuances
effectivement on assiste à un
appauvrissement généralisé des forces de
police dite régalienne
on le voit au niveau des commissariats
la plupart des commissariats de paris
petite couronne et en province et encore
pire où on pourrait citer des exemples
comme marseille où il ya une vraie
désertification des services de plus de
la nuit vous avez une voiture de police
au cours ce qui est une aberration
absolue
une fois qu'on a dit ça faut savoir ce
que l'on veut est ce qu'on veut des
policiers partout effectivement est ce
que l'on veut des policiers efficace ce
qu'on veut et ce qu'il est absolument
nécessaire d'avoir des commissaires
partout vous avez des hauts de seine par
exemple où il ya une démultiplication
des commissariats sur l'ensemble de la
zone
vous en avez très peu où il ya
suffisamment de policiers pour la faire
vivre ça c'est un point ensuite
quel est l'avenir de la sécurité dans ce
pays est ce qu'on doit tout déléguer aux
polices municipales et non seulement aux
polices municipales mais aussi à tout ce
qui est je dirais alternatif privé et
pour moi c'est un danger c'est un danger
si ça n'est pas contrôlée ici ce n'est
pas mise sous tutelle
justement par les autorité régalienne
les préfets notamment et l'état va pas
là mais bien sûr par l'état pourquoi je
dis ça dis ça parce que il ya des bons
il ya des mauvais mer tout simplement si
vous avez un maire qui gère sa
circonscription en bon père de famille
avec une action de la police municipale
cohérente qui va dans le cadre de
l'intérêt général
tout va très bien maintenant si vous
avez un maire qui considère que sa
police municipale est une forme 2010
particulière qui va lui rendre service
dans des conditions parti notamment des
élections je dis attention danger
attention danger il ya eu faute d'infos
sur ce que je suis un contrôle réel on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi il ya plus
de policiers nationaux on va mettre des
policiers municipaux et tout va très
bien dans le meilleur des mondes
non tout va pas très bien dans le
meilleur des mondes si ça n'est pas sous
contrôle tout simplement parce qu'il va
falloir se poser aussi la question de
savoir quelle sera la relation de ces
policiers avec la justice aussi
c'est pas le moindre des débats parce
qu'on parle d'eux je dirais la relation
poli citoyenneté pour des aussi parlé à
un moment donné c'est un débat très
complexes entre police et justice
et là il ya un vrai sujet on l'abordera
peut-être pas aujourd'hui parce que
c'est très compliqué compliqué
j'aimerais juste que dire un mot quand
même de cette fusion que sont certains
semblent souhaiter entre la gendarmerie
et la police la police absorberait la
gendarmerie la gendarmerie seraient
démantelés vous avez fait allusion on le
sait c'est un syndicat de deux
commandants de police de comines
moi j'ai toujours eu le problème entre
les deux alors qu'en est il ce serait
souhaitable c'est une ineptie
quel intérêt si les deux pieds parce que
quand vous encore une fois précis et de
regarder des tendances non devant et pas
simplement derrière le le développement
que ce soit en france ou dans le pays
c'est qu'on va vers des méga mall des
métropolisation ce qu'on appelle donc
des très grandes villes avec des
périphériques s'était pas à pas et par
contre coup dont peut avoir des zones de
périphérie des zones rurales qui vont
être relativement délaissés et si vous
regardez la perspective du
vieillissement astaire à 2040 2010
on va avoir des zones rurales avec
beaucoup de personnages et donc fragile
donc exposé comment vous mailler le
territoire pour justement assurer un
niveau de sécurité dans la
métropolisation qui va être compliqué et
également dans les zones rurales qui
sont relativement excentré et c est donc
pour moi la gendarmerie sa vocation
c'est le territoire c'est là où elle
peut elle à la connaissance intime elle
s'occupe
je dirais pas simplement que des
problèmes de sécurité elle a aussi un
rôle social et est donc je pense que
fusionner c'est une aberration
il faut laisser les deux corps
travailler et les spécialiser justement
par rapport au développement urbain et
par rapport au développement des
territoires que l'on pourra avoir
et encore une fois avec le
vieillissement pas ce qu'est ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
regarde dans les sondages des
municipales la sécurité c'est la
première attente
donc vous êtes avec aujourd'hui 16
millions de retraités avec les pensions
de réversion stach stach l'électorat qui
votent le tallec part active au delà ces
curés
mais cet électorat il va mécaniquement
augmenter avec la démographie c'est à
dire qu'on va passer si vous voulez avec
un nombre de seniors dans ce pays à 2040
parce que c'est là où il attend
lancement et plus et à 2070 on va avoir
un cortège de gens âgés extrêmement
important et il est à nous la réforme
des retraites avant la réforme dernier
est extrêmement important donc les
aspirations à la sécurité ne peuvent que
croître
et donc il faudra bien trouver des
réponses par rapport à ces problèmes là
nicolas peschier la gendarmerie je pense
pas que ça puisse se faire ça me semble
être une hérésie
on n'a pas faim si effectivement quand
ils opèrent en zone rurale et on a des
prérogatives sont similaires mais enfin
ça reste des militaires on reste une
force et civils armés nous n'avons pas
la même formation la fin pour moi de
fusionner ces deux corps me paraît être
impensable voilà jean pierre colombiès
je vois c'est une vue de l'esprit c'est
un vieux serpent de mer
chacun veut absorber l'autre faut savoir
que la direction de gendarmerie d
pendant que nous parlons développe des
directions parallèle avec des
spécificités identique à celle de la
police sont absolument pas dans la
dynamique de l'absorption d'une
quelconque façon sûre historiquement la
gendarmerie est très ancienne c'est une
vieille dame une très vieille dame et je
les verrais mal ce dès septembre mais
sans rien dire ils ont une implantation
territoriale qui est considérable il est
vrai que la police y est urbaine et
périurbaine ça c'est évident j'invente
rien la gendarmerie est très implantée
au niveau des territoires des maillages
et donc au niveau des élus et des élus
des sénateurs ou et de bon nombre de
députés vous imaginez bien que ni les
uns ni les autres vont perdre leurs
interlocuteurs privilégiés sans aucune
manière
alors qu'elle qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire en ce moment même en on est en
cours d'élaboration du livre blanc de la
sécurité
donc il sort c'est bâtir la police ou de
du 21e siècle
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait préconisé
qu'est-ce que vous
imaginez qu'ils faudraient pastore
changer pour que ça se passe le mieux
pour que les français est enfin
confiance dans leur peau lisse ou en
tout cas que le climat soit moins
délétère entre la pop il de la police et
la population
j'ai envie de dire qu'il faudrait
peut-être faire un résumé de 500 pages
et éventuellement du livre blanc déjà
pour pouvoir prendre le temps d'exposer
c'est à dire que c'est en ça on saurait
pas par où commencer
les problèmes sont tellement nombreux et
en fin de compte les problèmes sont
aussi les problèmes endogène c'est à
dire que globalement bon sur cette
fusion justement décor
police/gendarmerie bon allez presque
effective c'est à dire que les gendarmes
étaient autrefois mystère de la défense
ils ont été rattachées au ministre de
l'intérieur
au plan administratif donc ils ont
travaillé tous les deux sous l'autorité
justement des procureurs donc
globalement il ya un certain nombre de
modifications effectivement au point du
point de vue législatif et mad même du
point de vue matériel et j'irai à
envisager
parce que monsieur parlais tout à
l'heure du maillage territorial des
hauts-de-seine il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a plus besoin
finalement d'avoir un certain endroit de
présence physique de policiers les
caméras de vidéosurveillance justement
qu'ils sont encore une fois du ressort
des maires sur les communes peuvent
parfois pas liées justement à la
présence de policiers à l'importation de
poste de police
on a des dispositifs aujourd'hui par
exemple tout ce qui est verbalisation
sur la voie publique notamment sur des
communes de paris et les communes
limitrophes
ce sont des dispositifs qui était
déléguée à des sociétés privées il ya eu
quelques incidents on a eu quelques
conducteurs par ci par là qui étaient
parfois démunis de permis de conduire
sous l'emprise de stupéfiants etc on a
un fort en fait on a calé volet lié au
rodage au troll n'était pas vraiment
fait que oui moi aussi ça effectivement
il manquait l'aval de l'état c'est à
dire que moi entre à salariés un
fonctionnaire qui fait l'objet d'un
processus de recrutement pointilleux
dans quête de moralité et c'est bon ils
pouvaient parfois y avoir quelques
différences ne pas généraliser bien
entendu mais on se rend bien compte que
bon tout ça normalement ça doit pouvoir
créer 2
a donné de l'oxygène aux services de
police est actuellement ce n'est pas le
cas l'après plainte en ligne
à l'ère du 2.0 la communication via les
réseaux sociaux que peu utilisé la
préfecture de police
on voit qu'il ya quelque chose en fait
effectivement qu'il ya un train de se
passer qui en théorie devrait pas
justement autorisé la diminution des
effectifs mais peut-être justement le
haut fonctionnaire de police et de
gendarmerie d'ailleurs de pouvoir se
recentrer sur leur mission mais là j'ai
le sentiment plutôt du phénomène inverse
c'est à dire qu'on délègue certaines
prestations à des organismes privés on
délègue certaines de nos missions aux
polices municipales qui sont de plus en
plus nombreuses aujourd'hui sur le
territoire on à la vidéosurveillance on
a les services internet les prêts
plainte en ligne
et pourtant j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
toujours autant de difficultés sur le
terrain c'est à dire que quand je vais
déposer une main courante au
commissariat la dernière que je suis
allé déposer c'était deux heures et
demie d'attenté j'ai pas compris
pourquoi quand je suis arrivé en fait
j'ai demandé aux policiers qu est ce qui
se passe il ya des personnes avant moi
il ya pourquoi est-ce que j'ai attendu
aussi longtemps on a eu en plus d'être
policier je n'ai pas dit je n'ai pas dit
justement parce que j'aime bien pouvoir
jauger de la porter plainte rapidement
devoir mais ce n'est pas nécessaire je
peux personnages et pas de privilèges
particuliers en tant qu'utilisateurs et
si vous voulez j'ai voilà et au point
que c'est presque dissuasif c'est à dire
que j'ai constaté des faits il ya peu de
temps qui me concernait pas directement
je voulais aller faire un signalement
comme ça on débat passé déposer une main
courante et j'ai été dissuadés j'avais
pas 2h30 à perdre en fait vous voyez
donc du coup il ya tout un tas de choses
à repenser sur l'émission justement des
services de police parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a un vrai problème d'efficacité
sauf pour revenir au premier sujet en ce
qui concerne la répression des
manifestants mais pour le reste on est
très mauvais nicolas peschier mais déjà
je pense que pour que les rapports sa
meilleure entre la population et sa
police
il faudrait déjà redonner du sens au
métier je pense que un policier qui est
heureux et convaincu de ce qu'il fait le
retranscris sur sur le terrain il
faudrait donc abrogé de manière
définitive parce que effectivement sur
le papier ça a été assez c mais en fait
c'est toujours d'actualité faudrait donc
abrogé de manière définitive cette
politique du chiffre
abolir ces primes clivante qui donne
envie aux policiers de
de ramener comme on dit du bâton parce
qu'on parle de base de bâton chez nous
pour avoir ces 500 ou 600 euros sur la
paie du mois de décembre en fin d'année
parce que c'est ça aussi la réalité
c'est que la police et comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est aussi un
gilet jaune et on est à 500 euros près
quoi donc quand on vous tend 500 euros
devant le nez en vous disant si tu
ramènes tant de personnes on va te les
données et bien forcément ça ne peut que
dégrader les rapports entre la
population et sa police
ça ne peut que dégrader dès lors qu'on
n'a plus que qu'on laisse plus place à
l'initiative
forcément ça dénature le métier ça que
ça crée de une sorte d'aigreur une sorte
d g ensuite ensuite sous toujours sous
l'air de monsieur sarkozy il ya une
énorme déflation du corps d'encadrement
les applications auxquelles
appartiennent donc les gardiens de la
paix et cette déflation a aussi engendré
le fait que ce qu'on souvient tout à
l'heure qui est qu une voiture de
patrouille sur un département la nuit
que on attend de 2 heures et demie pour
une prise de plainte etc
il faudrait renforcer les effectifs de
police de manière à pouvoir accueillir
plus de manière plus convenable le
public à ce qui est moins d'attentes
dans les salles dans les locaux de
police à ce que quand on appelle pour un
tapage on n'attende pas trois heures on
doive par passé quatre ou cinq fois
l'appel
tout ça ça ça génère forcément de deux
de tension de la rancoeur et de
l'attention de la part la population
vis-à-vis de sa police évidemment du
renoncement même parfois aidé fois de la
résignation et le jeu patients 4-2 série
de mesures il ya des mais des mesures de
court terme
et puis des mesures de plus long terme
les mesures de court terme c'est dans un
pays qui a les contraintes que l'on
connaît vous dépensez 25 euros pour les
forces de sécurité mourne mille euros
c'est à dire en fait c'est 0 85% du pib'
donc la première chose c'est de donner
des moyens supplémentaires en
équipements mais également
revalorisation salariale parce que tous
nos amis là ils font des heures
supplémentaires plus ou moins payés ils
ont forcément des contraintes
bon on a vu certains soit oublié de
payer leur transport en commun avec sa
enfin ou leurs parkings fois je veux
dire il ya des choses aberrantes quoi
leur équipe ou lorsqu'ils ont compris
alors oui j'avais heureusement on paye
son propre équipement serre que
l'équipement que j'ai fournis par
l'administration lés tellement
obsolète on vous donne des chaussures
qui sont tellement rigide qu'on dirait
du carton donc aller courir derrière
donc on s'achète de nous mêmes
chaussures on s'achète nous mêmes nos
noces alors on fait tout ce qui est
fourni par l'administration est
tellement inconfortable c'est certain
que ceux qui les ont dessinés et conçus
il ne les ont jamais porter c'est
certain que donc on est obligé d'avoir
recours à nos propres deniers pour
s'équiper donc déjà ça commence par là
et le confort au travail
ça commence à commencer par là et donc
il faut il faut et c'est pour ça que ça
à débat citoyen quelle est la place de
la paix c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut
attribuer comme moyen donc moi
personnellement je pense que au sein de
notre association
on veut qu'ils aient des revalorisations
voc à dire des statuts qui soit je
dirais amélioré je pense aux asvp par
exemple etc
donc premièrement des moyens
supplémentaires et c'est un choix de
société
parce que si on laisse les choses aller
en pierre de toute manière ça va
continuer de se dégrader et les
vocations pour entrer dans les forces de
l'ordre pour diminuer en tant que tel
parce que j'ai évidemment il ya aucun
intérêt à faire ça
2 je pense qu'il faut protéger nos
forces de l'ordre et les familles et
c'est à dire qu'il faut que lorsqu'on
fait des agressions contre les forces de
l'ordre aient sciemment y ait des peines
exemplaires qu'ils soient décidées pour
avoir un effet du choisi parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une crise de
l'autorité
vous pouvez rentrer avec votre voiture
donc un peu lisse et au croisement
ça a pas l'air de poser de problème à la
justice etc
donc il ya un problème spécifique je
crois c'est le problème des mineurs
parce que c'est un sujet de fond comment
on aborde ce problème là avec les
exceptions de minorités avec des mineurs
qui n'ont pas d'origine ni de rien et
qui sont je dirais qu'ils posent un vrai
problème au niveau du suivi médian
voulait dire qu'ils migrent aux réfugiés
que dont on vous épargne la halle des
enfants si vous des dons ne reconnaît
pas la nationalité donc pour tenez pas
le nom qu'on met dans des structures
carcéral dédié et qui finalement
n'arrivent pas du tout à s'intégrer
qu'on relâche dans la nature sans aucune
formation n'est rien et qui participe
dada de cette dé la corse
guy d'ailleurs aux joueurs un peu ce
problème
de l'image qu'on a de la délinquance
issue de la diversité etc
ça c'est un vrai sujet parce que on le
voit à paris cite souvent l'exemple des
petites boules de marocains qui sont
jeunes soient et quel impact et sa
caractérise une situation si vous voulez
donc si on n'arrive pas à régler ce
problème-là policiers vous dire quel
rapport avec la police c'est que on
laisse des foyers de délinquance sur
lequel la police n'a pas de marge de
manoeuvre si vous voulez elle les arrête
mais s'ils remarquent et là le citoyen
ressent la sécurité en permanence et il
considère que la police fait pas son
boulot et c'est donc il ya des mesures
de court terme et je voudrais respect ya
des mesures de long terme c'est que le
numérique va beaucoup impacter notre
société ça pose des problèmes y compris
de démocratie donc là je vous renvoie
plusieurs ouvrages et que la réflexion
pour devrait avoir dans un deuxième
temps c'est comment repositionne cette
problématique de sécurité for the earth
dans une ère qui va être digitaliser et
pour lesquels les rapports vont
forcément être transformé gens bien
colombien ouais j'ai essayé d'être
synthétique par rapport justement au dif
robot gpal fut 500 pages ça c'est
rédhibitoire
je n'ai pas encore lu mais bon là où je
veux pas pour ce résumé des choses ce
qui manque surtout c'est quelqu'un à un
moment donné qui réfléchissent et qu'ils
raisonnent en termes d'intérêt général
et pas simplement en termes propres à se
valoriser par rapport à une bonne idée
qu'il aurait eue dans un certains
bureaux du ministère car ça on en crève
on en craindre que plus de vingt ans où
chaque ministère c'est à succéder se
sont succédé les uns aux autres avec
chacun l'idée lumineuse de créer enfin
le dispositif qui serait le plus
efficace on a eu la police de proximité
on a eu la police de résultats on a eu
les zones prioritaires de voix puisque
c'est un bloody boulga d'idées très
mauvaises pour la plupart en tout cas
pas cohérente qui fait que là encore et
le flic perd le sens de ce qu'il fait et
la citoyenneté ne le perçois pas ne sait
plus ce qu'il fait il faudrait pour
arles est vraiment dans une idée simple
véritablement revenir au bon sens à la
cohérence et oublier simplement que le
flic n'est pas qu'un élément répressif
yves de la société mais il doit être ce
qu'il a toujours été d'ailleurs un
interlocuteur
les polices municipales plutôt la police
nationale n'existe pas depuis très
longtemps
elle existe depuis 1941 avant c'était
déjà des polices municipales dit on à
conserver sur modèle là qui est très
probablement perfectible comment doit-il
évolué je pense qu'effectivement il ya
plein de paramètres qui doivent être
pris en compte
la digitalisation mais pas que ça
véritablement et j'en reviens à mon dada
qui est le judiciaire la chaîne
judiciaire parce qu'à véritablement il
ya un écueil une vraie problématique en
termes d'actions policières et de
réponse judiciaire
si on ne s'attaque pas à ça c'est comme
si on pédaler dans le vide
parce que véritablement plus personne ne
sait ce qu'il doit faire merci tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]